ils sont rentrés tard de leur réunion à
poissy et surtout dépité après quatre
heures de discussions
l'intersyndicale n'a pas obtenu de la
direction des éléments concrets pour
justifier la fermeture du site
d'hérimoncourt une grosse déception une
réunion décevante
tout simplement parce qu'on est allé à
paris pour avoir des réponses
donc on n'a pas eu de réponse claire et
concrète
beaucoup de chiffres qui pour nous ne
correspondra pas grand chose on sait
qu'il y aura pas d'avenir pour les
salariés de psa
donc il faudra penser à la reconversion
nous ce qu'on ne veut pas entendre à
l'intersyndicale mais il compte sur le
prompteur position la position de psa
c'est de faire des économies sur le
foncier et le transport en délocalisant
les activités vers vesoul et sochaux or
selon les syndicats le foncier ne
représenterait que 95 mille euros à
l'année quant aux transports les
économies serait dérisoire
sachant qu'il y a huit camions qui
viennent donc souvent un peu de toutes
les performances en france et en
l'occurrence ils mettaient beaucoup
vesoul en avant vesoul il ya un seul
camion qui vient elle transport coûte
231 héros donc que les économies on veut
bien mais je pense ça peut abuser
l'intersyndicale a émis plusieurs
propositions pour sauvegarder l'emploi
et le site
mais la direction les a refusées les
élus eux dénoncent les méthodes abusives
du groupe
je pense que il faut que ces grandes
sociétés apprennent à respecter les
territoires respecter les territoires il
ne les respecte pas pour l'instant
quand on prévient comme cela nous allons
faire nous ne discutons pas et qu'on se
met à discuter une fois que la décision
est prise
c'est tout à fait inacceptable une
réunion avec le préfet du doubs les élus
locaux et des membres de la direction de
psa se tiendra ce vendredi à 10 heures à
la sous préfecture de montbéliard
[Applaudissements]